mehr tempo beim auszahlen der hilfen
mehr mut beim öffnen und blogger an die
wirtschaft macht druck der
wirtschaftsminister verspricht
unterstützung
was bringt der schnelltest im kampf
gegen das virus ab märz soll er für alle
zur verfügung stehen und zwar umsonst
und alexander zverev und die jagd nach
einem großen titel in australien wird
nichts daraus im duell gegen novak
djokovic zieht er den kürzeren
die nachrichten nicht erst heute mit
christian sievers in einen guten abend
zum überblick über diese nachrichten
dienstag sport natürlich auch wieder in
der sendung mit kristin otto hallo und
genannt die bundesregierung will bei den
hilfen für die schwer corona geplagte
wirtschaft nachbessern
das ist eines der ergebnisse eines
gipfel gesprächs des
bundeswirtschaftsministers mit über 40
verbänden heute die beklagen dass auch
die existierenden hilfe nur schleppend
liefen und sie fordern nachdrücklich
eine konkrete perspektive ungewissheit
sei mit das schwierigste in der
derzeitigen lage mehr von last boden
sack schon am morgen war es vorbei mit
der ruhe eine gruppe junger unternehmer
macht vor dem wirtschaftsministerium
ihrem unmut luft wir erhoffen uns darauf
dass wir wirklich eine klare öffnungs
strategie haben das zielwerte festgelegt
werden damit unternehmen wie
beispielsweise die gastronomie oder die
hotellerie wirklich auch in ihren
unternehmen und in ihrer persönlichen
planung im fahrplan haben an denen sie
sich orientieren können
forderungen die sich der
wirtschaftsminister auch von den 40
verbänden anhören musste
die er heute zum spitzengespräch geladen
hatte wir sind entschlossen die
hilfsmaßnahmen immer anzupassen an die
lage wir haben aber auch die begründete
hoffnung
das ist für viele bereiche eine öffnung
perspektive beim nächsten mal geben wird
eine ankündigung mit zweifelhaften wert
schließlich liegt die entscheidung über
öffnungen bei den ministerpräsidenten
konkreter wird es aber für solo
selbstständige sie können jetzt einen
einmaligen zuschuss bis zu 7500 euro
erhalten
außerdem werden die überbrückungshilfen
auch auf großunternehmen ausgeweitet die
einen jahresumsatz von über 750
millionen euro haben
das geld fliesst bislang allerdings
immer noch zu langsam
ein drittel der betriebe wartet immer
noch auf die vollständige zahlung der
november lief bei der dezemberhälfte
sind es 75 prozent der unternehmen die
opposition bezeichnet den gipfel als
flop das was der wirtschaftsminister
heute gemacht hat weil die verlängerung
des chaos war die verlängerung der
existenzängste viele unternehmerinnen
und unternehmer
wie es konkret mit ihnen weitergeht
haben die unternehmen heute jedenfalls
auch nicht erfahren und schauen wir mal
auf ein paar konkrete beispiele was
läuft da schief
die regierung sagt es gebe ja eine
vielzahl von angeboten soforthilfen
überbrückungshilfen kfw kredite und mehr
doch viele unternehmen entgegnet das
ganze sei zu kompliziert die gelder
würden zu langsam fließen
und manche firmen und selbstständige
fielen bislang ganz durchs raster
klaus thomsen hat sich das in hamburg
mal genauer angesehen
ariane beim online-verkauf mit der
notmaßnahme wollen sie und ihr mann die
mehrere modegeschäfte in hamburg
betreiben wenigstens etwas umsatz machen
kaum mehr als ein tropfen auf den heißen
stein ihrer verluste seiner ist vom
heutigen gipfel beim wirtschaftsminister
hatten sie mehr erwartet na ja man ist
enttäuscht also weil man denkt somit ihr
könnt es doch umsetzen und ändert doch
jetzt einfach was also macht doch die
läden zumindest stückweise wieder auf
und unter den altbewährten hygiene
konzepten die staatshilfe für dezember
und januar konnten sie erst vergangene
woche überhaupt beantragen wenn sie
fließt ungewiss dabei fördert krone auch
noch eine starke bedrohung für den
einzelhandel in den städten in den
online handel wächst und man im prinzip
da nur auf einen begrenzten pula
menschen zugreifen kann als kunden
dann kann man seine fixkosten immer noch
nicht mehr decken
unternehmen wie die offroad manufaktur
bekommen überhaupt keine beihilfe weil
sie mehrere standbeine haben nur der
werkstattbereich ist als systemrelevant
geöffnet die hohen verluste beim verkauf
von zubehör und abenteuerreisen werden
aber nicht berücksichtigt werden wir das
nicht mehr durchhalten
das muss zum frühjahr das muss ich sag
mal im april/mai allerspätestens wieder
so laufen dass wir hier unseren laden
wieder richtig öffnen können wie viele
firmen überhaupt keine beihilfe bekommen
ist unklar
das so der verband der
familienunternehmer sei noch nicht
einmal statistisch erfasst
kostenlose schnelltests für alle hat
gesundheitsminister jens spahn
angekündigt er schlägt vor ab märz soll
jeder einen anti gentest machen können
bei geschultem personal etwa in
testzentren in apotheken und arztpraxen
antigen schnelltests werden jetzt schon
eingesetzt zum beispiel nach gronau
ausbrüchen und den pflegeheimen und
kliniken
das ergebnis ist nicht ganz so
zuverlässig wie bei den sonst benutzten
pcr tests im labor aber dafür viel
einfacher zu bekommen schon in 15
minuten ja schnelltests plötzlich sind
sie in der politik in aller munde und
jetzt soll offenbar tempo gemacht werden
manche werden sagen jetzt erst theo koll
guten abend was steckt denn dafür eine
politische strategie dahinter
nun könnte die frage auch rein
logistisch beantworten es sind jetzt
endlich genug stellte s verfügbar um
wirklich alle
damit versorgen zu können aber das wäre
in der tat zu kurz gesprungen politisch
steckt dahinter das thema öffnungen und
natürlich auch der wachsende unmut der
menschen zum ersten sachsen hat gestern
die schulen geöffnet kommende woche
schließen sich weitere bundesländer an
dann die friseure und so weiter das
heißt die gefahr von infektionen steigt
wieder deutlich und da sind natürlich
dann flächendeckende schnelltest ein
mittel um die folgen der lockerungen
möglichst unter kontrolle zu behalten
und zweitens sind angesichts der
schleppenden impfstoffversorgung und der
kritik daran die schnelltests so eine
art überbrückungs technikum trotz des
mangels dann weiter öffnen zu können
übrigens geht die bundesregierung davon
aus dass diese von geschultem personal
vorgenommenen stellte es an bedeutung
verlieren werden sobald die selbsttests
für laien verfügbar sind und das könnte
schon sehr bald soweit sein
herzlichen dank für diese analyse heute
abend und dann gucken wir jetzt auf die
aktuellen daten für deutschland die
sieben tage incidents liegt unverändert
bei 59 bei den neuinfektionen meldet das
robert-koch-institut 3856 neue fälle
binnen 24 stunden
das sind zwar 477 mehr als vergangenen
dienstag da waren die daten allerdings
unvollständig weil 600 fälle aus
nordrhein-westfalen fehlten
528 menschen starben in verbindung mit
im kampf gegen korona watt armin laschet
der nrw ministerpräsident und cdu-chef
vor einem zu einseitigen fokus auf den
inzidenz wert man könne nicht immer neue
grenzwerte erfinden um zu verhindern das
leben wieder stattfinde
beifall kommt von der fdp kritik von spd
und grünen wer von erfundenen
grenzwerten spreche zerstöre vertrauen
inzwischen betonte laschet dass er
natürlich zu den beschlüssen von bund
und ländern stehe
fragen an armin laschet nachher im heute
schon ein jeder vierte der in
deutschland arbeitet tut das wegen
corona vorwiegend oder ausschließlich zu
hause
das hat eine umfrage der
gewerkschaftsnahen hans böckler stiftung
ergeben
seit ende januar sind arbeitgeber
verpflichtet beschäftigten wo immer
möglich home office anzubieten damit
arbeiten fast wieder so viele menschen
von zu hause wie während des ersten
shutdowns im april so viel zunächst zum
thema corona jetzt weitere wichtige
themen von heute die deutsch russischen
beziehungen sind auf einem tiefpunkt das
hat viele gründe unter anderem auch den
sogenannten tiergarten mord seit oktober
läuft der prozess
rückblick im august 2009 10 wird mitten
in berlin ein georgier erschossen aus
angst vor verfolgung war er nach
deutschland geflohen
der kreml nennt ihn ein verbrecher und
mörder fast noch am tatort nimmt die
polizei einen verdächtigen fest war dem
es ein russischer auftragskiller glauben
die ermittler
heute kam der wohl wichtigste zeuge vor
gericht zu wort felix zimmermann
berichtet der mutmaßliche täter vom
berliner tiergarten mord konnte schnell
gefasst werden ein russischer
staatsbürger
doch wer steckt hinter dem anschlag
auftraggeber des mordes sei der
russische staat so lautet der vorwurf
des generalbundesanwalts und auch die
angehörigen des opfers sind hiervon
überzeugt das ziel der familie des
opfers ist dass in dem verfahren
festgestellt wird dass der mord durch
russische staatliche stellen in auftrag
gegeben wurde die these vom russischen
auftragsmord stützt die anklage auch auf
nachforschungen von berlin
eine journalistische organisation
bekannt etwa durch recherchen zum
abschuss des passagierflugzeugs m h 17
über der ukraine unter strengen
sicherheitsvorkehrungen sagte heute vor
gericht ein journalist vom berlin cat
aus er behauptet der angeklagte sei mit
einer falschen identität mit hilfe
russischer stellen nach europa
eingereist
nach recherchen von berlin cat soll der
angeklagte auch mehrere tage in einer
trainings einrichtung des russischen
geheimdienstes verpasst haben
auf anfrage des zdf gibt die russische
botschaft folgende stellungnahme ab die
recherchen von verschiedenen
inoffiziellen strukturen und
privatpersonen sind nicht verifizierbar
und können als vertrauenswürdige und
zuverlässige informationsquellen nicht
betrachtet werden von der
glaubwürdigkeit des solisten vom bett
hängt maßgeblich ab ob das gericht im
urteil zu dem schluss gelangt dass
russische staatliche stellen hinter dem
mord in berlin stecke ein urteil im
tiergarten mordprozess könnte bereits im
april fall mehr als elf jahre nach dem
verheerenden luftangriff im afghanischen
kundus ist der fall juristisch
abgeschlossen
der europäische gerichtshof für
menschenrechte hat entschieden dass die
deutsche justiz ausreichend ermittelt
habe ein bundeswehr- oberst hatte den
luftangriff auf zwei tanklaster
angeordnet die von den taliban gekapert
worden waren
bei der explosion wurden auch dutzende
zivilisten getötet die aus den lastern
benzin abzapfen wollten
deutsche gerichte hatten klagen gegen
den oberst abgewiesen da ihnen kein
strafbares verhalten nachzuweisen sei
jetzt gucken wir nach frankreich wo der
radikale islamismus ein thema ist dass
das land nicht zur ruhe kommen lässt
frankreich will dagegen hat heute per
gesetz vorgehen die frage bleibt ob das
funktioniert kein europäisches land hat
mehr gelitten unter dem islamistischen
terror
charlie hebdo weiter klar netzer und im
vergangenen oktober die enthauptung des
lehrers samuel partie das sind nur
einige der anschläge
insgesamt wurden in sechs jahren etwa
260 menschen durch islamisten ermordet
christel hs jetzt über das neue gesetz
und wie es frankreich verändern soll
dieser mann ist lehrer in einem pariser
vorort seit kurzem steht der unter
polizeischutz
es gab drohungen gegen ihn weil er
öffentlich von dem immer stärker
werdenden einfluss der islamisten auf
die anwohner und auf seine schüler
gewandt hat vor einigen jahren waren es
einzelne die werte frankreichs abgelehnt
haben jetzt sind es ganze klassen die
klassen
es ist ein bekanntes problem in
frankreich ein teil der muslimischen
bevölkerung der sich immer stärker
radikalisiert und aus dem immer wieder
terroristen hervorgehen zuletzt mord an
einem lehrer angriff auf eine kirche der
stadt will jetzt durchgreifen mit hilfe
eines neuen gesetzes das die
nationalversammlung vor einer stunde in
erster lesung verabschiedet hat künftig
werden drohungen gegen vertreter des
öffentlichen dienstes mit bis zu fünf
jahren haft bestraft
eine straftat begeht auch wer aus böser
absicht private daten veröffentlicht und
heimunterricht wird stark eingeschränkt
also die möglichkeit sein kind nicht in
der schule sondern zu hause zu
unterrichten
reber lüthi das gesetz richtet sich
gegen radikale gruppierungen die
muslim-bruderschaft etwa oder die
salafisten wir müssen zeigen dass wir
klare regeln haben viele muslime lehnen
das gesetz grundsätzlich ab es
kriminalisiert alle praktizierenden
muslime oder stellt sie zumindest unter
verdacht radikalisierung bekämpfen ohne
eine ganze glaubensgemeinschaft an den
pranger zu stellen
das ist die große herausforderung vor
der frankreich jetzt steht zurück nach
deutschland 75.000 menschen sterben
jedes jahr bei uns an einer sepsis einer
blutvergiftung die dritthäufigste
todesursache ist das bei uns und heute
startet eine kampagne die über die
gefahren dieser erkrankung informieren
will und darüber wie man ihr vorbeugen
kann
bei einer sepsis kommen zwei dinge
zusammen eine infektion das kann eine
äußerliche wunde sein aber auch eine
infektion im körper zb in der lunge und
eine überreaktion des immunsystems
darauf die kann dann so stark sein dass
organe und gewebe lebensbedrohlich
angegriffen werden
gabi handelt jetzt mit wichtigen details
vor anderthalb jahren hatte lisa bühler
eine sepsis also eine blutvergiftung die
ersten krankheitszeichen waren ähnlich
wie bei einer grippe
doch dann verschlimmerte sich ihr
zustand rasant ein medizinischer notfall
beide unterschenkel mussten amputiert
werden
und es gab folgeschäden erst vor kurzem
bekam sie eine neue hüfte
ich hatte auch nicht damit gerechnet
dass es fast anderthalb jahre später
noch folgen mit sich ziehe ich dachte
eigentlich mit den amputationen und in
hand
aber ja dass da noch so spät was
auftritt dort keiner mit gerechnet
das problem bei der sepsis die ersten
anzeichen ähneln einem grippalen infekt
die frage wo wechselt der harmlose
infekt zu lebensbedrohlichen sepsis ist
so schwer zu beantworten das selbst
krankenhäuser probleme haben schnell
genug diese situation in der
ernsthaftigkeit einzuschätzen wenn sie
einen bestimmten punkt überschritten hat
deshalb sollen die symptome einer
blutvergiftung bekannter gemacht werden
dazu gehören hohes fieber extreme
atemnot niedriger blutdruck und auch
verwirrtheit bei lisa war eine minute
kochen infektion der auslöser bakterien
die sich im rachen befinden und
ungeimpft schwere krankheiten auslösen
können
dank guter prothesen und physiotherapie
bewegt sich die 25 jährige mittlerweile
wieder wie eine gesunde junge frau und
das freut sie am meisten
wichtiges thema jetzt was ganz anderes
wäre gerne lange und weit verreist kann
sich um einen ganz besonderen job
bewerben mit die europäische
weltraumagentur sucht astronautinnen und
astronauten einen masterabschluss etwa
in naturwissenschaften oder medizin und
einiges mehr dann könnte es klappen
alexander gerst ein mann mit
entsprechender berufserfahrung meint wer
diesen traum hat der sollte sich
bewerben linken klinge
für alexander gerst ist mit seinem
reisen ins all ein kindheitstraum wahr
geworden und für künftige einsätze muss
er weiter regelmäßig trainieren auch um
auf lebensbedrohliche situationen
vorbereitet zu sein
ein astronaut brauche keine superkräfte
sagt er müsse aber stresssituationen
aushalten und teamfähig sein mitbringen
muss ist ja einen sinn für abenteuer
naturwissenschaftliche ausbildung oder
auch medizin oder auch eine
ingenieurwissenschaftliche ausbildung ja
und die bereitschaft ja viel zu reisen
und neues zu lernen das ist das wichtige
nach elf jahren sucht die esa wieder
neue astronautinnen und astronauten und
hofft dass sich auch viele frauen
bewerben
denn bislang gab es erst zwei esa
astronauten im all nun werden vier bis
sechs feste und bis zu 20 reserve
astronauten ausgewählt und zum ersten
mal ist auch ein spezielles programm für
menschen mit körperlichen behinderungen
geplant es soll keine grenzen geben
das heißt wir müssen natürlich sehen
welche kandidatinnen und kandidaten sich
bewerben und welche anforderungen
notwendig sind auch in der raumstation
oder für den transport um diese meiler
möglich wer es am ende schafft
astronautin oder astronaut zu werden
kann vielleicht so wie alexander gerst 2
ss fliegen oder sich sogar einmal auf
eine noch weitere reise begeben
die nächste bemannte mission zum mond
ist bereits geplant
ich habe schon leuchtenden augen gesehen
bei kristin otto aber noch ist sie hier
unter den sport ja nehmen alle auch weit
weg aus dem open also down under
alexander zverev ist in melbourne als
letzter deutscher profi ausgeschieden
und muss weiter auf seinen ersten grand
slam turniersieg warten
er unterlag dem weltranglisten-ersten
novak djokovic der trotz häufiger
rückstände die oberhand behielt genug
gelegenheiten hat alexander zverev in
diesem viertelfinale
immer wieder lässt er den achtmaligen
australian-open-sieger djokovic
verzweifeln nach gewordenen im ersten
und verlorenem zweiten satz zieht zverev
im dritten mit einem break davon das
gleiche gelingt ihm später auch im
vierten doch titelverteidiger djokovic
spielt in diesem match immer dann sein
bestes tennis wenn er mit dem rücken zur
wand steht
nachdem der serbe einen satz ball von 12
zum 2 2 satzausgleich abgewehrt hat
verwandelte er seinen zweiten matchball
12 unterliegt mit 7 zu 6 2 6 4 6 und 6 7
erneut keine medaille für die deutschen
biathletinnen bei den
weltmeisterschaften in pokljuka in
slowenien über 15 kilometer war
franziska preuß nach zwei schießfehlern
als siebte die beste wm gold ging völlig
überraschend an die tschechin makita
dawydowa nach insgesamt sechs
wettbewerben kein podestplatz für
deutsche das gab es noch nie und knapp
vorbei am stockerl hieß es auch für
alexander schmid bei den alpinen
weltmeisterschaften in cortina d'ampezzo
ein missgeschick bremste ihn im parallel
slalom aus er nimmt volles risiko und
wird nicht belohnt alexander schmid
rechts stürzt im kleinen finale kurz vor
dem ziel weggerutscht mit dem innenski
vierter platz für den allgäuer lauf
konkurrent leute ja aus der schweiz
sichert sich weltmeisterschafts punkt
der feder ist sehr bitter passiert und
jetzt ist halt der undankbare vierte
platz aber man muss damit leben
gold im parallel slalom geht an den
franzosen felderer er schneller als der
kroate süptitz frankreich vor kroatien
und der schweiz und mal keine medaille
für deutschland ein bei dieser wm fast
ungewohntes
ja vielleicht morgen wieder wintersport
live bei uns morgen von 12 uhr 10 an
vielen dank als ersatz für skiurlaub
quasi hat sich dann christin die
zitterpartie beim wetter ist erst mal
vorbei
in den nächsten tagen wird es fast schon
frühlingshaft aufwarten auch bei den
autofahrern wie hier in wolfenbüttel
niedersachsen hatten die feuerwehrleute
allerdings noch spikes gebraucht um den
wagen von der straße zu schieben
echte probleme auch beim zugverkehr in
hamburg und lautstark wann sich der
eisbrecher von rügen aus seinen weg mit
rund 600 ps durch die ostsee und sein
ziel auch heute die inseln hätten sie
vom tiefsten winter in den vorfrühling
das geht bei uns jetzt sehr schnell
details gleich von katja horneffer im
heute-journal freut sich dann der
kollege claus kleber auf sie 21.45 wir
sehen uns morgen wieder wenn sie mögen
bis dann und in allen einen angenehmen
abend
[Musik]
genau wie meine damen und herren
kräftige tiefs beenden jetzt die kalte
phase in mitteleuropa
dieses tief yukon kriegel sich hier sehr
schön ein sein zentrum erreicht derzeit
schottland gut zu erkennen ist auch
dieses wolkenband das erstlinien förmig
heranrauscht sobald es auf den kontinent
kommt wird aber immer mehr eine
wellenbewegung raus und das hat den
regen dabei und die milde luft die ja
von südwesten heran kommt die macht sich
schon in der nacht bemerkbar im westen
nämlich sinken die temperaturen acht bis
5 grad im osten wird es kühler
da sinken die werte auf 2 bis minus 1
grad und deswegen müssen sie sich da
auch noch mal auf blätter einstellen
denn es fällt häufig regen in der nacht
die er verlässt uns dann morgen ostwärts
auch an der nordsee fällt etwas regen in
der mitte und richtung süden wird es
aber immer freundlich am freundlichsten
zwischen dem oberrhein und dem allgäu
die temperaturen steigen in der
südwesthälfte morgen bereits auf neun
bis 14 grad im osten im nordosten ist es
deutlich kühler mit 4 bis 8 grad in den
nächsten tagen wird es von tag zu tag
ein bisschen bilder der regen der am
donnerstag herankommt verlässt uns schon
am freitag und am samstag liegen die
höchstwerte bei 7 bis 18 grad schön
abend